[Applause]
[Applause]
rather
that incredible voice came from
ten-year-old Roberta Battaglia from
Tirana
who impressed everyone with her powerful
cover of Lady Gaga's shallow but before
her performance Roberta was very nervous
who do you want some water thank you I
got tiny see when she finished her water
the little superstar was ready to blow
everyone away with her singing voice
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
her voice is on real now after Roberta
received a standing ovation Simon gave
her words of encouragement after she
opened up about being bullied sometimes
I do get bullied so yeah oh okay well
you know we hear this unfortunately a
lot but there's one way you be you win
over bullies it's by being happy and
successful you know that and then Sofia
Vergara surprised the young singer with
the golden buzzer it was amazing it was
breathtaking you're ten years old that's
impossible to sing like that at ten
years old and you know what let's see
who is going to bully you after this
[Music]
[Applause]
now I got the chance to interview
Roberta earlier this morning where she
told me what was going through her mind
during that memorable moment I was just
saying oh my god like I wasn't saying it
that I was thinking it I was I was
saying oh my god she's gonna give me the
golden buzzer she's gonna kill me
and then my mother obviously was crying
and I was crying and it was just mixed
emotions I mean I didn't know whether to
laugh cried
it was an amazing amazing moment now we
all know Simon can be a bit of a harsh
critic at times but Roberta opened up
but what it was like to get his stamp of
approval he can be judgmental but he can
be nice at the same time I mean he just
he speaks his truth and like any judge
should and when it's good it's good and
when it's bad it's bad and but I think
it's encourages people to you know move
ahead and do better the next time right
I mean she's pretty wise beyond her
years now Roberta also spoke about what
it would mean to win this season of
America's Got Talent
it would mean the universe not even the
world it would mean the universe I mean
just being there meant the world now it
would be it would mean the universe now
because I would win I can't wait to
watch you perform during the live shows
because you know I'm gonna be rooting
for our Canadian girl so what did you
think of Roberta's performance on
America's Got Talent
let me know in the comments below
[Music]